why is everything so far away
you
okay in a guy where
okay so too far okay so now we're gonna
do let's work out that that's right
[ __ ] we're in there that's where I
batches okay wait okay and it's jamming
for 36 minutes [ __ ] my thing is
hard as a [ __ ] rock it compares a
diamond okay [ __ ] let's go handsome
pasa ya know baby let my hand I mall
monster I say I'm time to look at myself
in the mirror and cry now this is a good
game nexon said where it did the [ __ ] it
took underneath here yeah what the [ __ ]
thank you for coming so quickly
I heard about the execution I can't
believe they killed your missionary
Martin I'm sorry brother Andrews I have
to say they didn't rise I had
unless that I hope we haven't
disappointed you lately I let's say this
batch as I look at this guy [ __ ]
skinny legs let's go eat something fo i
believe i'll survive but am I mistaken
does your God not require you die
is that not why is not a transaction
behind cat sailing requires nothing of
us he has granted as a chance to become
something greater we divide our week
someone were here to meet someone at a
bank life to millions of new worlds we
are simply accepting the opportunity his
glow presents whatever were making so if
you found the launch key you wouldn't
use it dead I don't know are you afraid
I'd be mad to say I wasn't but we've
made a home for ourselves here pretty
good out here a family a place you
belong
exactly the nucleus it is a blessing of
the truest order it would be hard to
leave such a gift even if it is for
another Dima I recover the tapes
martensite excellent yes let me take a
listen good to hear his voice
no pleasure in twisting the word this
tape should be sufficient to pique the
high comparing his trust before
approaching should help guarantee right
you'll then have to dispose of the
remains once you're done uh-huh I'm
ready then I won't
I can't manage
my house got Sammy I'm gonna like tell
her hell I what an error oisin that
coming here oh [ __ ] her hair you tracked
Kasumi here I'm impressed perhaps not as
quiet
okay that's there that's an S I'm just
gonna [ __ ] I got a high persuasion
I'll get him I got him I together
shutter him
hmm my nose feels like there's bacon
okay okay where is he or are you kind
sire the world extreme that reason I
can't buy some things you haven't mm-hmm
I'm just here of course look it's a
lesson just stay on the high confessors
now there's something I can show you and
not sure if the flow bothers you but I
can help let's see what you have Adam
provides okay
I have to take out a chance
ok now
now I need some missiles so razor I need
you choose that right actual right away
that once let's chat with your high are
they
I know my white bench ah there you are I
have a job for you be respectful you
walk through hallowed halls
hi all right yeah what does ah captain
EO welcome brother how does it feel to
take your place among Adams chosen
that's an honor I'm glad you feel that
some sure you've been to Farber yes seen
its barriers against uh what would you
do this giant for harbors a hellhole
precisely you want to wipe out that it
for years my predecessor bed we tried to
happen now that I am high uh huh all of
it they will come too but it is only
through you yes he's not crazy what I
recovered a holotape confessor Martin is
planning to come back and take over
Martin glad I won't read [ __ ]
ash at eight when they make us do this
because I never find the [ __ ] cuz I've
so many tapes are in something just
[ __ ] [ __ ] my pants
yeah yeah that listen children cactus
time is over
the nucleus must prepare for a new order
mine I can't believe it he's alive none
of the other children can know about
this okay command center you said I'll
ensure we aren't disturbed
ok
didn't get here [ __ ] here
Oh what the [ __ ]
I know that you can hear me it's finally
ready to fulfill your responsibilities I
gotta get the [ __ ] out of here this
place is crazy and a lot of rats here
perfect this is the perfect meeting spot
I know you're there let us discuss this
table let's fry this [ __ ] come on don't
mind my friends these children have
proven they can be trusted unlike some
you walk into my chambers carrying that
Traverse [ __ ] and expect me to believe
you simply happened upon it if you value
your life it's over Texas dimas edema
leave I you're not bluffing there is no
place beyond his reach on this island is
there sure
hey Scott
excuse me hi confessor get away from me
traitor I die Oh shet
oh great it is again
okay don't mind my friends these
children have proven they can be trusted
unlike some you if your voucher it's
over Texas dimas edema yeah as [ __ ]
how many times we got a [ __ ] Davis I
thought you were able to kill the guy
quick safe don't mind my friend the hawk
and if you've uh it's over Texas dima
sent me to kill dima don't mind my
friends these if you've uh huh it's over
Texas diva Lee there is a cat cat
s is full baxton a ham how cuz thats i
got bath oh that's a cool gun Jesus
ok all right ok not just recognizes
right it sounds like quite the
experience but I'm glad to know there
will be peace on the island again
awesomes vision was clear on the matter
I
I must thank you again for sheltering
while under its sway think nothing of it
you're welcome to stay as long as you
might you are too kind even I should
only need just a little more fresh so
Dima get a question
why do you even call me
you know me before the personality in
front and we didn't have names inside
the Institute and after the personality
experiments started the only name you
ever called yourself was Nick Valentine
if there's another name you prefer I'd
be happy to know oh I like the name
when you wear something for a long time
seeps into you of course
I convince them I'm starting to envy
team
fine
children and that here
and of course you are well
it's out for her Amish